The solutions for this equation were 2 plus or minus i. Great work if you found
these. We start by identifying the variables or the coefficients, a, b, and c.
a equals positive 1, b equals negative 4, and c equals positive 5. We plug
these into our quadratic formula using parentheses around each of the
variables. Here, we'll have the negative of negative 4, which is positive 4.
Here, we'll have negative 4 squared, which is 16. And these three factors will
give us a product of negative 20. Our denominator will be 2 from this product.
And then, we simplify our radical to get the square root of negative 4. The
square root of negative 4 is 2i, and then we can factor a 2 from our numerator.
So we can simplify one last time. 2 divided by 2 equals 1, and we're left with
2 plus or minus i.